michelle obama says it was never easy
being the wife of a driven politician
the demands of campaigning and politics
strange their marriage she says and they
sought help in couples therapy
plus in their first national tv
interview together we also hear from the
woman who helped make the first family
work
michelle's mother only on cbs this
morning marion robinson tells us
about her eight years in the white house
but first michelle obama
talks about marriage you've had a
complicated relationship it seems with
politics
so as as the woman who was married to
this man
every time barack came to me with
the idea of running for an office i was
just like please don't do this
pick another career you're gifted you
went to college you got a law degree
you could do anything else besides this
there's so many ways to save the world
but every time i had to think to myself
that approach is selfish because i knew
i was married to
someone who was gifted and someone
who could contribute and but for the
fact that i was married to him and i it
would be
hard on me i would want him to run
yeah but he was always a different kind
of guy there's a different guy
different dude there's a great story in
the book he said
you wake up one night and he's staring
into space is he thinking about his dad
or
something bothering him and what was he
thinking about it's like
income inequality it's like really dude
i thought you were dreaming about me so
you knew that he was different
you're very candid about talking about
marital counseling
you know i i tell young couples it's
like when you get married you've got
that moment those
those years if you're lucky where it's
just the two of you
individuals on your paths you come
together when you need to
it all works until you have kids
your first joint project where the
inequalities are felt you know i'm
working
and managing child care
and sick kids and trying to coordinate
my job
and he's flittering in there tensions
started to
to arise and we knew that we needed to
have a place where we could really work
these feelings out
was he like great let's go to counseling
oh no yeah oh no i can't wait to go
he was barack is a problem solver it's
like i'll buy a book
and we will study relationships
relationships and we will study chapter
12.
you read chapter 13 and we can figure
this out
you know it's just one of those things
like we don't need help from anybody
and i was like because for me i was like
i need to go to somebody who's going to
tell you
you're wrong you're wrong exactly and i
talk about that it's like well i didn't
get that
the period of counseling for me was a
turning point because
i learned that i was still responsible
for my own happiness
it wasn't his job to solely make me
happy i had to figure out my
space in this do you still feel if we
need to go back we would do that even
absolutely even though that you're so
well known now oh gosh yes
that doesn't yeah i i think counseling
is one of those tune-up times
marriage is hard all marriages are hard
um and even look i you you know us
i love my husband we have a wonderful
marriage
but it takes work work that was made
easier thanks to her mother
marion robinson the whole eight years
you were in the white house i think i
could count how many times i saw you on
tv and i got up to one and then i had to
stop
yeah it's just not something that you do
but why is it that you didn't want to do
interviews mrs robinson
i didn't want to say anything that would
you know how you accidentally say things
yeah i figured if i didn't say anything
then i wouldn't say the wrong thing we
don't have to worry about that
when your daughter becomes first lady of
the united states and your son-in-law
is a president how do you wrap your
brain around that what are you thinking
it's pretty difficult let's face it
why because i felt like
this was going to be a very hard life
for both of them and i want was worried
about
their safety and i was worried about my
grandkids
i mean that's what got me to move to d.c
why did you want her there why was it
important to you oh because
for the girls you know i i wanted them
to come home to family there was just
parts of
the girls lives that i just knew were
going to be okay because mom was there
when i traveled
internationally grandma was there you
know when i wasn't home at the end of
the day
grandma was there when the kids were
still little and they needed to have
someone be with them in school i mean
you think about my girls were being
driven around
in a motorcade of three cars
with at least four grown adults with
guns in each of those cars and i just
thought
that that's an unnatural way for a
little second grader to go to school
well mom would ride in the car with her
to make it feel like a regular car pool
you're in the white is where they say
mrs robinson can we get you something
mrs robinson do you need anything right
was that a big adjustment
it was a huge adjustment as a matter of
fact i talked them into
allowing me to do my own laundry you
were doing your own laundry
yes and she taught the girls how to do
their laundry they would go upstairs for
laundry
lessons and she was the most beloved
figure in the white house let me tell
you she had a stream of people
the butlers the housekeepers they would
all
stop by and they would grandma's room
was like the confessional
you know everyone would go there and
just unload you know and then they'd
leave
people still visit mom in chicago they
do some of the staff
come and if they're in town in chicago
they visit her
do you feel you have your life back do
you miss the white house at all
no no not at all
you have your life no i do miss the
people yes
because they they were like family to me
and we got pretty close
there your mom says she doesn't miss the
white house do you
uh no no i mean the eight years was more
than enough
and what i realized over the years is
that
home is where we are you know and the
white house happened to be our home
for eight years uh but we took all that
love and energy
and we just moved it to another house
it's still there
um and that's the part of that's the
part of life that's important
what's the best thing about michelle
obama that makes you proudest
well now i my saying is when i grow up
i would like to be like michelle obama
we all just went oh wow even the crew
what a beautiful thing between mother
and daughter you can clearly tell
they're really very tight
and you know she tells mrs robinson
tells a funny thing that you know
michelle obama was always a feisty
little kid she said i actually could
stop raising her when she was nine
because she was that good yeah and you
can tell that they are very very
well connected and and michelle says
that personally and professionally
she wouldn't have had the life she had
if her mom hadn't been there because you
know you can always count on your mom
and to be there for the girls to make a
carpool somewhat normal
right when you have armed guards and
three other cars following you with the
grandma sitting next to you and she was
so low-key guys you never heard a lot
about no one would say mrs robinson such
a character
yeah because she wasn't trying to be
part of the family in a public way
she loves her her children barack and
michelle and loves her grandchildren
but she also had her own life and so
she's very happy to go
back to her own life yeah and i think
too you hear about
the presidents and first ladies and
families that are most respected who've
been in the white house
are ones that treat the people who work
there as family
not as staff check check but as family
that's what they did they still visit
mrs robinson and here's to you mrs
robinson indeed
you're gonna be singing that all day
everyone loves you more than you could
know
and today on cbs this morning podcast
you can hear our entire interview with
former first lady michelle obama and her
mom that's marion robinson find the
podcast on apple's podcast app or
wherever
you like to download your podcast you
got lots of options gonna be a good
podcast